Hi everyone. Sorry I'm a bit late. Bad news. I'm feeling a little under the weather by
under the weather. I mean, not sad, but like, you know, not well. So if I sound a bit funny,
I apologize for that. That's just me. That's just me, but it's because I do have emergency
stuff in here. And I will, and then I do have a BRB screen in case I need to like, you know,
yeah. So there we go. So forgive me, it really just happened not too long ago. I was coughing
up. I felt like I was coughing up the lung. So if if I if suddenly I would I start coughing in a
nice sound weird. That's why. Did you eat some bad color fish? No. No, I wouldn't eat. No, maybe.
Next question. Anyways, probably nerves. Yeah, probably nerves. But welcome everyone to my two
point. Oh, the debut debut debut. Sorry. debutant. We'll get right to business. I like I like getting
my charts out of the way. So we'll start with tags first. No, general take is not indulge. A general
take is a tag that I want for you guys. If you guys want to be like, Oh my gosh, I love Mercy so
much as you should. Oh my God, I love Mercy so much. I want I want her to see my my love letter
to her that I posted on Twitter. I need something like that. So I'm thinking I'm thinking I'm thinking
I'm thinking just mercy mode east. Which one of these would a fan song go under? I believe that'll
be art. I know it's like, I said art is like modellus list. But like, music is art. Anything is art.
Hear me out. Okay, that was pretty good.
Scissor mercy, scissor me, mama mercy. I'm not the mama here. I'm not the mama here. We've
got three mothers. We've got three mothers, which is, of course, mom, a mommy being one mother,
second mother being, um, Azura, who has lovingly given us a raid. Thank you so much.
And as well as she be she be the toilet is, uh, is our third mother.
Excuse me.
Don't die though. I'm so sorry. I like literally. I get really flummy sometimes. That just happens.
It just happens. Oh my gosh. Is that meadow and meadow and chat. Hi. I'm you met plus. Wow.
Wow. Gosh, it's not twitch. So I can't give you a shout out, but y'all follow you met plus girls.
They are so cute. Have mercy. Okay. I love the, I love these tags, except for one thing.
One thing my lovely senpai, my senpais is that, um, we gotta make them sort of unique
so that, you know, some rando, I don't either one take over some Randall's tag, although I can.
I too, I don't, uh, it doesn't get mixed in with like someone's, someone's book club, you know?
Shear me out is a good one. Yeah. You know what? Shear me out is a good one. Yeah. You know what?
Yeah. Heck yeah. Let's do that. You know, here for my general tag is
Shear me out. Wow. So good.
Modesty cuts. Modesty cuts. Shear me out. Yeah. That's pretty good, right? So if you write me
love letters, it's a general tag. Just be like, Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Mercy. Shear me out. Okay.
So it's good. Yeah. Uh, live. Personally, I don't know if I like
mm online because mm online was just like Mercy Mode East online. Mercy time.
Mercy time for live. That's a good one. I'm not as creative as my lovely senpais. My senpais are
also amazingly creative. Sounds like MMO. Yeah. That's my issue. That's my issue is that it sounds
like MMO and I was like, Oh, you're right. Time for mercy. Show mercy. That sounds like
I'm literally taking over a tag that of someone, of someone at their like little book club.
That's gotta do. No mercy. Mercy. No mercy.
Stock o'clock. Mercy lane. Snippity clippy. No. Snippity. Snippy clippy for clips. That
sounds good too. Big for mercy. No mercy. Sheer time. Mode East live.
Streaming mercy. Like screaming. Oh my god. Cosy too high. Oh my god. These are really good.
Mmm. I like that. I like that. I do like that. Streaming.
How about this guys? Okay. Stream for mercy. Huh? Huh? Anybody?
Stream for mercy. Do you like four as the number four or like the word four?
Like you can do like a stream, stream, stream, stream,
for mercy versus stream, stream, for mercy. What do you guys think? Four for sure? Okay.
We're all such a team. We're such a team. And this is why I keep you guys in my basement.
Four is the more I hit with the kids.
And in before Sheer Me Out is also an Ask Me Anything tag for people who Sheer Sheep. Oh.
No. We're good. We're good. We're going to take it over. We're going to take it over.
Okay. So clips, clips, clips, clips. Let's do some clips.
I like it down here, but maybe you can install it in dehumidifier. No.
Wait. I don't know the difference between a dehumidifier and a humidifier. The reason why
I'm just like a humidifier has like, it causes moding. And I don't want that. I want you to live
in the best situation ever, Senpai. That's why I put in like those shiny glow in the dark
stickers of stars. So it looks like you're laying underneath the stars in the cage.
Modest clips. Clips out for Mercy. Snippa Snippas is a fan name. No.
Modest clips, knee clips. Snips, moda snips.
Mercy moment's good. Thank you for about two, two, two, two.
Mm-hmm. Off cut, sneak in live, cut clips, Mercy snips. Snips is good. Snips is pretty good.
It's like, you know, like if together we work together with my snippets.
Mm-hmm.
You guys are so creative. I'm taking a bunch of your ideas and it's brewing in my little,
my little cavity of a mind. Where's the clip for us?
You're killing me. Stop it.
There you go. Oh my gosh, my face. My face is like so red from laughing so much.
Okay.
Okay I have someone make sure it's not being used there's no way we can get away with this
Oh yes we can you know what company I'm with
It's not used
We're there okay art art modelist you guys like that
Art of stalking okay, that's pretty good you guys like this or do you like something else?
Oh
Merciful for art, but the current one works
Actually the the current one was thought up by Azra isn't all my gen mates are so much more creative than I am
Merci merci lost Marcellus
He modi's oh
Oh
That's good
That's good you guys are so smart
Excuse me. I'm so sorry. I as I said feeling not that great. I get really flimmy sometimes
I like that I like immo
Deast
Immo Deast
Yeah, I thought molded loose it loose. I was like like for short for illustration
I thought it would be really good for
For like an alt take as well, but then I was like
That was better as a little as a regular art tag
I'm so proud good thing good thing you're cooking
You guys get my senpai's get get five minutes out of the Darrow dog cage
You can go for Waxies
Love Waxies. Let's go. Yeah freedom. Don't you guys like it guys might have to wear muzzle, but that's okay
Haha, can I request an additional minute instead? No
Now it's scarier out there. Don't worry. I'm right next to you
I'm right next to you. So don't worry about it. Mmm. Art tag. You guys like it at modi loose
Can I stay in the cage you guys want to stay in the cage? Oh
Of course, it's cuz I made it so nice in there, right? Can I get a tail?
Can we watch real again sure you guys can have anything you want for being such good senpai's
Someone said clip art earlier and I kind of love it. Okay. Yeah, but you know what's gonna be in clip art
Ha ha clip heart. Oh
The art of stalking
Wait
Wait, that's pretty good like modi's modi's but like more modi's artist like artist mode Darst
I
Call high craps
Modest art scissors paint
Mm-hmm modi's start mode
Dean art mode art like Mozart. Mmm. Okay
Modest and emotes is kind of good. Oh, I get it so that they work in a pair. Mmm. I understand. I understand
But like modi's is already my last name
It's
Shot for
That's not short. Wow. What am I saying? It is
It is French
For a dressmaker
Honestly when I first heard my name Mercy Mercy modi's I was like oh like Mercy like mercy. Thank you dressmaker. No
Ha ha ha ha ha ha
Not freaking mark. No, what do you think I am like a shopping district? No
call hi canvas
Modi start emotes start works
Paper mercy like paper mercher, but you didn't like had him beat
When I first got the name, okay, so
Strongie strongie gave me the choice of names
She vetoed already vetoed at that time. Had am had am beat
So I was like, okay, uh, so she's like, okay, you can choose a new name
And I said, okay, give me a second. Give me a second. I'm gonna think of something real clever, right?
Oh
Hold on I need to start Google something because I need to remember why I picked a certain name. I
Need to find the right word because I'm kind of stupid
Okay, okay, okay, okay, I got it again. Okay, okay, so at first at first I I picked a name
I
Picked a name so I picked the name when I first started. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh
You're off you're off kayfabe. We're we're gonna like riot right now
Okay, so
The name that I chose was Lane
L8 I and
Beetled I chose Lane because of Chamber Lane
I
Last name was always going to be Mojist
Lane like Lane
Lane
Short for Chamber Lane, which is like, you know, Victorian ladies have this like a little belt
Belt where they would have like sewing supplies on them. So I took the name from like Chamber Lane
Which I was like, oh, yeah, I'm so creative this is gonna so pass
This is gonna pass so well like this is perfect and then
Stranny was like
So the staff wants to call you mercy and I said
Actually
It was you
But yeah, I would chose that and then it got of course
Beato
Let's see
I
Mercy's a good name, I think so I think so. I would have vetoed that one too shut up shut up senpai's
Don't agree with them
Anyways
Meme Modi's nuts, maybe if you like
I've just said I got tired I got tired of ideas so Mo DeLustis is gonna be it
I don't think she would like that
I don't think she'll like that
Mean takes perfect a bit awkward on the tongue is whatever you're writing it down. You're not saying it out loud
It's fine
Someone said hearts and crafts. Oh, that's really cute. Has anyone picked hearts and crafts yet?
That's my issue like it sounds like something like grandma would be like
Or a charity would do a charity would be like
Everybody take hearts and crafts for sick children
Okay
There's no way that's not taken right as you see I was like, okay
More de Lisa like the Mona Lisa is my smile mysterious Senpai
I
Arts and stabs
Is that taken is that taken it sounds like it would be taken by like a college art group
Everyone's so creative. Yeah, me mercy like me mercy, but like me mercy. It's free really
Mine you ain't
I
Wait, what was it again
Arts and stabs
Oh
Snuff stands this isn't Jojo all right some stabs
Not Jojo, sorry
Art stand stab. Oh shut up
So
You guys don't like Modest, okay? Well the other choice I saw which people seem to like was my my nurse mercy
Me it's it's a mean mercy
It's a mean mercy like me
I
Mean mercy isn't taken all right. Wow. Wow. Wow. Look at that
It is finally complete then la la la la la any objections
I'll make this really cute by lower casing everything
Well, yeah, okay, okay, I mean I'm our song
Awesome awesome awesome
Clifford so curse shut up. It's great. I think it's great
You got to use it comic sans fonts
Want give me a second. I don't know if I have comics
Let me move this over
So, thank you everyone for your input
I
Since you guys were so good my senpais were so good here you go. Wow
Anyways anyways
Some of you may have realized why do I have reincarnation of Julius Caesar?
I have a friend one of my gal pals one of my gal pals message me went your birthday is the death of Julius Julius Caesar
I was like and
then
It hit me
scissors
Caesar Caesar
What was my code name before I was released stabs
actually
Jimmy it's you strut
Oh
You guys are you guys are so funny my senpais are so funny
Yapping in front of my salad. Oh gosh
It's too mercy
Oh
We're just joshing around we're just joshing around imagine big red circle right in front of me going is this real
Julius see scissors dying it to bootay is this real chat
I
Did you mercy it I
Saw it I saw it was so funny
So I did I thought it was funny and I thought I would share with my lovely senpais
I
Was so funny
I thought it was so funny when I came to that realization. I was like, oh my gosh. I need to share this with everyone
Merceason desist. All right, we're move on then
Yeah, all right, all right are we leaving clip clipper is of course we're leaving clipper is do you not like that?
Excuse me, do you guys not like that? I
Think it's the best I think it's it's it's honestly perfect
All in favor say I'm the only person that matters is me
All right, moving on let's talk about other stuff Wow I
Have some questions
That I picked out personally because some of you guys
Most of the things I'm so really surprised most of my morals are not
Questions they are a lot of elements
So I'm very very very very very happy a lot of them are compliments going like I love you
I love you. Good luck on debut and I felt really really really inspired and I felt like you know in
Dragon Ball where they were like give me your energy
And
Then I like gathered everyone's energy and then I I managed to make it through debut
I was super nervous, but I still do it anyways. We'll talk about some of my likes and my dislikes a little bit
All right
We're there any of them compliments about your patreon audio
Um, yeah, I was actually surprised because I was like
I'll talk about this more after I answer this question. You know what we gotta we get we need to have order in here
Senpai otherwise you go crazy and we can't have you going crazy
So
Hold on. Let me get this out of my way
My my my my my notepads in my way
You said you like SMT4 in debut, so how do you feel about SMT5 apocalypse play through play through when it comes out
Okay, so I won't answer this truthfully. I have SMT5 and
The reason why 5 is not my favorite and I wouldn't play apocalypse is because
beacons
When I played, you know, the little exploration area and the 3d exploration area. I got a really bad motion sickness
I
Really bad
Motion sickness. I was just
I was uh, uh, I don't know why 4 was great probably because it's on a
And a smaller screen a smaller screen on the DS. So I was I was probably okay with it, but when I
I
Play played 5 I was like
But I bought I bought for you for you guys. So I have a theory I want to test with my senpai
So with my senpai's I want to test the theory, which is I'm going to slowly build
my
My uh tolerance
To 3d 3d motion and 3 games and I'm gonna see if I can build it up
through years
So I know a lot of a lot of people
Grew up with games. I did not grow up with games
So I figured maybe I can play games like
well
Uh gold and I
Like gold and I
And then move on through years
Through the years to play more modern games. Does that make sense?
I feel like I I feel like that's what I should do
Get motion sickness glasses. Guess what I do have those dorky
Motion sickness glasses. I wonder if I still have
If I have I make them into an ass that long long ago
Hold on
I have these dorky ass glasses
That look like this so they have like
Uh little liquid the the thing is that it's supposed to
So
Help with uh motion sickness. Um because of the liquid will help stabilize blah blah blah something signs you can look it up
Anyways, uh
I bought I went out and actually bought these glasses
Real not fake
I bought these glasses and guess what the liquid in them evaporated
And evaporated and I went now they just look like dorky glasses
Oh
It's okay
What I would rip off. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, it was but I got it on sale
I got it on sale for like three dollars three three dollary dues
So it was fine
So it was fine. So that's why I have like super bad motion sickness
Um, do you guys want to hear a story about how I discovered I have motion sickness?
So
I've done this story many times already
um
To classify what sort of sickness motion sickness I have it's specifically screen sickness
Yeah, so
So screen sickness I was in class
Okay, I sit in the front row of class because I'm a try hard student
honors all that
Okay
I I work hard and school in school
So
Shut up. Yeah, I'm a good ko hi. I'm a good ko hi
I'm a good ko hi. I paid off my I paid off student loans and stuff with with basically
grants and scholarships
Anyways, so a science eating. No, I wanted to sit in the front because I one I can't see
I have is it near-sightedness where you can't really see far away
Anyways
I I forgot I forgot so yeah near-sightedness probably, um
I sat in the front and then we watched I was a screening so I took a lot of
Cinematography classes and and film studies classes because I really like I really like films. I really like film. It's really fun. Um
So
I sat in the front and then we were watching 2001 a space Odyssey. You're gonna hear about the story a lot
2001 a space Odyssey is a story that oh that always comes up
And to that space Odyssey, you know the stargate sequence
so, you know the stargate sequence where um
What's his face is going through time and then it's going really fast and you he's just going whoa
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So that that part I was watching that part intensely and then
I was like, oh, I'm starting to cough
And then I threw up in front of everyone
And
That's how I discovered I had screams slash most in most sickness
And then I had to excuse myself bathroom was there come back in clean it clean it all up
Ah
Life is uh
Life gets you hard
So if anyone remembers that day, uh, no, you don't
Yeah, don't know you don't it was on a big screen. So it was a big projector as well. So it was
Yeah, it was embarrassing. I didn't say that as like my cringe moment in life because I didn't think it was that cringe
I thought it was just funny
Cringe though. I've got so much cringe in my life. I had to pick something
Are you okay at the movies? Yeah, I'm okay most movies most movies are fine
Most if something kind of like, you know
If something, um
Oh, you threw up on the projector. Now I threw up all over like the desk and floor
Um, I go for the non 3d movies
So I don't I I picked the standard standard edition one
So I don't really get the glasses in or anything
So like projectile plummeting
Shut up shut up senpai
Sort of yes
Is there a certain genre you avoid like action or horror
At the movie for that reason, uh, there's a reason why I don't really watch like bay movies, you know
Hmm
But usually I tend to watch standard standard should be fine. And if I feel like I'm gonna like
I uh, I close my eyes. I don't see it. I close my eyes
So date night on john wick movie is not a great idea
Um, a john wick movie will probably be on like a standard tv size. So like just maybe like at home
At home tv. Yeah, are you guys saying you want to go on a date with me? Is that what you're saying?
So, um, I do not see it
That's why I don't really feel like I would play smt
Five apocalypse unless I played smt five first but smt five caused me to like
But smt four apocalypse was like really fun. I got stuck on one part though. There was an item that
Was an item there's a place that I tried to find but I couldn't find so I couldn't proceed with the game
for uh
smt four apocalypse. It was really fun though. I really liked uh playing it. Uh, I have fond memories of of um
of smt
smt force in particular. It's not very punishing. I don't think
And I I was able to finish it. So that's
That's pretty good
But mercy, what if you tried 2001 a space odyssey on acid?
I got offered that choice and I said
Thanks, but no thanks
How about roller coasters? I don't feel that great on roller coasters either. So I tried to avoid them
Some of them I do okay on which is weird
but
Uh, generally I feel like my motion sickness has been
mostly to do with the screen stuff anything with the screen. So if I see like, oh
First person stuff. Oh my gosh, like a game that I feel
Really makes me throw yuppie
Yeah, what's that free game more frame? Yeah, war frame makes me really throw yuppie
So that's one thing that I feel like knock turn I feel like was a little punishing for smt. So I didn't really like it
Yeah
Yeah, and then I played smt one
The ios because it was released on the ios and the touch buttons were really hard. So I didn't really
Go through it. Have you tried vr funny enough? I don't know why but I have less motion sickness in vr
But I just can't afford a headset
I I just don't have a headset. So I've been borrowing
Oh
Would you play vengeance smt five or no, mm same thing
They are cheaper now they are but I'm still
I'm so poor. I live with my parents. So you guys are stuck with me in my basement with my parents
You're welcome
Okay, so next question out of all the vtuber corporations out there, why did you choose to apply to this one?
Oh
This is a little bit of a harder question, but I guess the way I can sum it up is that scrawny gave me a chance
Um, I wasn't very
picky
so to say
with uh applying to places
So
I tend to I got a
I tend to choose
Places that I feel like I would probably thrive in
And so I would apply to there
but I'm not that
Picky
Picky so to say but at the same time when scrawny
When scrawny did the announcement. I was like, okay, I'm kind of interested in this company
I'm kind of interested in this company
Let's see and I decided to watch her stream talking about it
So
When I saw her stream talking about I felt very moved
I felt very moved like honestly
I felt like I was like, you know, you ever just feel like your heart throb a little bit when you see someone
Or you hear some some speech or see a wonderful movie. I felt that I felt that when I heard scrawny talk about the company
And
I was
Really, I was really moved by her goals and what she wanted and I actually truly believed in her dreams
So
I truly believe in her dreams. So
You know, I
am probably
I'm probably the least out of everyone here. I'm the least
familiar
with
asmr and
Asmr and kind of like, you know, the alternative stuff, right?
So
So, um
I'm still learning
The caveat when they said that
Uh
That you needed 18 plus experience. I do have that. I played a lot of of of of alternate games
So it's all new to you. Mm-hmm. Well asmr and stuff streaming and v tubing not so much
So I played uh
Errol gay basically, I'll just say it outright. I played Errol gay on stream
And that was enough that was enough
So I have to play, um
So I'm basically learning as I go so a lot of times I
Excuse me
Hmm
Okay, I um, I played
18 plus games
Uh, so I'm not familiar with asmr or anything. I
So when I signed on I was I would bother scrawny a lot like scrawny scrawny
What does this mean?
What is this?
So I would say something like, um, let's see one of my recordings. I was like
Really confused by something so
I guess I can tell you what it is. It's not it's not too bad. So I basically asked scrawny scrawny
What's the countdown?
And I would go scrawny
Do I have to say the numbers?
And scrawny goes, yes, yes, please say the numbers
Okay, I come back maybe another time going
I say brown noise, what does that mean?
Or I go scrawny
Why these globe things?
So I'm very I'm very ignorant
Ignorant naive
Dang did you almost talk a looty there? Yeah
So I would be like what are these? What are these? What does this mean? And I would just go like
I would
So I would bother scrawny a lot with them and she would be like it means this it means this
She's been very nice to me. I feel like there's time for should be like
Listen mercy. You probably just need to google it
I
I'm learning very slowly
But yeah, everyone's been super nice to me I've been
Kind of experimenting with certain things
um asmr is very new to me
so is kind of like
You know alternative content as well, so it's very new so please take care of me senpai. I'm literally giving you my virginity
Asmr virginity I should probably probably say that
So be nice, okay be nice, uh, there is an audio that I'm a little worried about that people might not
Like so just know that I'm studying I get feedback all the time
I get feedback from all the time and then
Um
And I'm improving all the time
At least I think I am
Okay
So I hope you guys are super understanding with that
Thanks
So I literally study a whole lot so since I'm so new to this I study a whole lot
I think the reason why I
am okay
At my which I'm really surprised people have complimented a lot on my first audio
I think the reason why I did
I'm doing okay is because I do have an acting background
I I have a very extensive acting background
All right, so let's move on I'm getting embarrassed now
Oh
Well all kind of acting
Stage plays movies television stuff like that
Things like that
So I have a bit of a bit of that I've also did a lot of training back
Back and make myself sound so old
Uh back when I was doing a lot of acting I took a lot of classes. So I'm pretty I think I'm pretty decently trained
But I'm really rusty. I'm really rusty
Yeah, I'm I'm super super rusty and uh
And so, um, I'm really polishing polishing it up with with this
Uh, yeah
Okay, what unique quality do you think makes you stand out from the rest of the girls for the sake of not being controversial
I'm not sure what they're trying to say. You're sorry senpai. I don't know what you're really trying to say by controversial
What unique skills do you think you have?
Are you having fun?
Um, of course I'm having the the blah blah. I'm having a blast
You mean it's all you don't really love us. It was on act. I didn't say that I didn't say that
It means I can be whatever you want me to be senpai, that's all
So
Uh, what unique qualities make you stand out from the rest of the girls
Well, I'm a different person first off my laughs are probably what most people
notice when they stand out that stands up the most and I have
Well a really different voice
Can you be somebody not like I like you anything
Wait, you're not yet every ends up. What the fuck do you mean put yourself back here right now?
Um, I guess I do have a little bit of the acting background so
And I think out of everyone
I think
I'm not quite sure I need I need to confirm this but I think I am
The longest streamer or the most
Season streamer
Out of my gen mates
Probably
Probably that what unique skills do I have
You can always argue that skills aren't unique and that they can be honed etc, but I would say that
That
I guess I'm truly in this
To improve and continually improve. I don't know. That's not really unique to me. You know what?
Forget this question
Frequent forget this question. I'm good at taking care of my senpais. I'm good at loving my senpais. I'm good at
At making sure that they stay obedient and don't break out of the lock
There's 10 locks on that by the way on that door
So I feel like
What makes me unique is being myself I suppose
Yes, I am in love with all my senpais, but I think in a way that is in self as unique charm
Jokes on you. I'm a locksmith. Not without hands. You're not
Oh
Dear you really want to do this. Oh, no, what am I going to do?
You have no
Oh
Now be good, okay, don't make don't do any funny ideas
Okay, don't do any funny ideas
I
Really will
I really will I've been so nice. I've been so nice. I gave you a home. I take you out for walks
Like what more do you want for me?
Okay
I
What do you want this this is the dream you're living with me. We're going to get married. We're gonna have three kids
Like what what more do you want?
Okay
So be good or I'll be very oh, you know, I'll be a little upset, you know
All right
Why just three well, I feel like they'll support each other very well
Oh
It's okay, I'll be the breadwinner
Sim
So we're all good
I'm winking but you guys can't see because I have a
Hey next question
Do you have any longtime girls as in girls girls? What's on my mind girls?
As a member of viola. Yes. I want to be here for a long time
So what I want is to do like 3d streams outfits
Um, continually, uh produce more content for all of you guys
and
And continue on on uh being a part of this company and hopefully
Hopefully, hopefully, hopefully have a bit of my dreams come true as well
And I want strong stream to come true. I think
I'm so thankful for straw knee
and
management and like basically every staff
That I get to be here. So I feel very thankful for that
And so I want to do my best in order to to give back
Their pay back their kindness
Have you seen
I've seen you wish for the sire fumo. Are you a visual fan of visual novels? Do you have favorite aroge? Yes
I love the show novels. Why because I can lay back and just go
So
So I like uh, so I like aroge. Um
The last
Aroge I played was gore screaming show and I really liked it
I really liked it. I thought it had layers like an onion. It had
Layers and I really liked it. Um
And another one that I really liked I do like saiyano uta
I I played saiyano uta when uh, I probably shouldn't have played saiyano
So I probably shouldn't have played that game at a certain age
Don't do that kids. Um
But I was enthralled by it. I was enthralled by the plot and everything. I loved it so much
So the last uh
Mercy did saiya do anything wrong? No, it was uh, what's his face the entire time?
She simply got corrupted my opinion
Hey garashi, I love you garashi too, but that's not at all. I think I like uh, what was the call again?
I answered this question already on on my twitter and on my moderals, but I can't remember
What was the name of it?
Oh, they translated it too much. How'd I know shoujo? How'd I know shoujo? I had fun. I had fun with that as well
um
Yeah
So I really like uh playing visual novels, especially kind of like darker visual novels
Uh that take a more grim look. I think another one that I recently played was oh shoot. What was it called?
It's a really old one. It's considered like, I believe it's one of the first
Eroge's to be like officially translated to a western market. What was it called again?
Divided. Yeah, I I recently played divided. You can actually play it for free now
It's like uh, I
Yeah, it's it's it's you can play it for free now. Mm-hmm
So I I really like uh playing a lot of games
Uh, especially if they're kind of like relaxing for me
Um, what I usually do if I stream visual novel games is I will voice the characters myself
Um, if the characters have voices, I try to mimic their voices
So I hope that's not too distracting, but that's what I'm gonna do and that's what you're gonna like senpai
What dead divided di vi dead
Yeah, but yeah, that's what you guys guys are gonna like that's what you're gonna take and I'm not gonna do it any other way if you're like
Oh, she's reading over the voices and I wanted to hear the voices. I don't care
Play it by yourself
Right now you're with me
All right
Amy said something about not
Having spicy accounts yet. Do you have a site in mind for it? Yes. I have a site in mind
Uh, I want to do the uh, what was it? Finsley?
So I want to do that especially for arrow gay
For arrow gay, I really like that and I had a
Good stamina for reading reading visual novels and gaming
So I think uh, we'll we'll play lots. We'll play lots. Uh, of course, I've asked management about it and I've asked Ronnie about it
and of course, it's uh, it's uh
We should probably establish
um
Establish ourselves on uh, youtube and and and as a content creator first before
Doing that. So I understand. So please wait patiently. Okay
Anything in real life now
I'm shy
I'm shy. No, really. I'm I'm super shy. Like I might seem outgoing now, but honestly, uh
I famously spent like entire week trying to talk to someone and then like I I took the the time to uh
Finally talk to a friend and I was like, ah
And I took me uh
Uh, hi
No hand cam, maybe that's the most you will get from me. It's maybe a hand cam
Maybe
It depends on how I feel
So
I'm like super shy. I'm like super super shy. No, seriously
Uh, I'm super I might seem outgoing. I might seem really ganky, but inside I'm internally screaming all the time
No, if you can no
Uh, no
I don't really know how that would be appealing and I haven't been creative enough to think about that
But no, no, I don't think so. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
I
May seem ganky, but I'm really stanky shut the fuck up ghoul
I introverted now
See the thing is I might I am extroverted
Because I always want to be around you senpai like I always want to be you guys
Uh always fill me up with such energy and it makes me feel really happy, but
I have introverted hobbies
So I don't make a lot of friends that easily with introverts or extroverts
Like I remember someone was like, oh
Do you want to go to a rave? No, I want to go home and watch the movies and stuff, you know, they're just like
Why are you so weird for not waiting to go to a rave and I'm like
So I've yeah
What movie
Probably at the time I wanted to watch uh
some kind of anime movie probably
Probably gentle cyber or something
So
Yeah, I would call myself an extrovert because I really do feel energy being around other people
um, but I would
Say that I appear more of an introvert and I have trouble talking to people because of
Like my hobbies are not exactly what standard extroverted people have as as as a hobby
What's your blood type? Why do you guys want to know my blood type?
So introverted extrovert something like that, I don't know I wouldn't put myself in a label too much because
Yeah, it just feels weird
I mean, I assume, you know, you know all our blood types, maybe
Maybe are you guys gonna do the the japanese blood type quiz on me? Want to see what my personality is?
I'll give you a hint about why my blood type is it's very common
The end
There you go
Have you played needy streamer overload? If so, what's your opinion on it? I played needy streamer overload
This is probably gonna be a little weird
Needy streamer overload is
Fun
I cannot listen to the soundtrack it hurts my ears. There's some kind of frequency in the game that makes me go
Oh, this fucking hurts
Out of this fucking hurts
Does that make sense
There's something in the soundtrack that i'm just like
I like literally rip my off my headphones and just go
So that's why I don't really
I'm not the biggest fan of needy streamer overload. I love its aesthetics. I love love the gameplay. I just
It hurts my ears
I don't know what frequency it is
It feels like when you are a kid and you could hear them and if you could hear the mosquito
Sound or something and then it just means you have that like certain frequency that you can hear
It feels like that it hurts it hurts my ears. It physically hurts my ears
So that's why uh, I also hope that i'm that insane
You're welcome
Played on mute. Oh, but if I played on mute, it's boring. It's boring
I'm not your senpai because I'm probably younger than you and that would make me your coal hides over shut up
You guys are all my all senpais. Senpai's not age. Senpai's not a gender
Except for senpai if you're if you if you are under 18, maybe you shouldn't be here
This was sent by a 38 year old
Senpai
Is you and I love you
truly sincerely I do
I
believe senpai is a mentor type person and you guys are also mentoring me through my journey through asmr as well
That's why everyone is senpai and I'm coal hide only me
So
That's why I feel like my senpais are all you guys. I know that your fan names are
snippets but snippets but
You are all my senpais and you and if you guys don't really like senpai sometimes I'll I'll I'll switch between
Senpai and darling
Okay
Well, you still be coal hide if we all are gets our son second gen
If second gen happens and if it does
They are the only ones that get to call me senpai
understood
Duh
Mercy is there pet name you like to be called by I like any pet names honestly, uh when
Senpai started to call me coal hide. I felt I felt you know, I felt really happy
I felt really happy. I feel like that's our pet name. Um, I don't mind any pet name styling honey
Baby
Anything works
Okay
Um
Um sugar biscuit, I don't know I don't know
Snookums I'm I'm all for it. I'm all for it
I
Therefore
Even like sweetheart
Pumpkin things like that. I don't mind
I don't mind although I do have an affinity an affinity with coal hide right now. Okay
Hmm time for a simple question. What is your favorite food? Uh
Thing that can eat so if you watched my debut senpai, I have said that I am allergic to eggs and
That is a huge freaking problem. Everything contains eggs in it
So, uh, I'm not that picky. Um
I
Don't like porridge because
As a child, I was hospitalized a lot
And they would always give me porridge every single freaking day
Every single freaking meal
So it reminds me of when I'm sick. That's all
Oh
Sorry, I go crazy. I go crazy seeing like other other other girls
I go seeing other, uh, corporal girls
Hi
But okay, sorry, sorry, I got distracted. But yeah, I
Can't eat eggs and therefore I'm very allergic to it and anything that contains eggs. I cannot eat it. So that means
Uh cakes I have to eat vegan cakes. Um
A certain certain ice creams I can't eat ice cream unless it doesn't contain that
And
All that all that stuff. So I'm super allergic. Uh
Another part of my allergy that happens is that, uh, there's a lot of things a lot of things
such as vaccines and
Medicine that I can't take because of eggs as well. So that's why my immune system is a bit weak
It's always been a bit weak since I was a child
So that's that's how it is
So eggs is a big hate. I don't like the word eggs. I don't like smelling eggs
I don't like seeing eggs. So for maybe like, you know, and in an anime like, uh, shugo chara
shugo kara
Kara for my character. Yeah
Those are fine
So I have a
Yeah, uh, maybe like, yeah, yeah, yeah, like maybe Easter eggs and chocolate eggs fine
But like I don't like eggs periods not the smell not being around them
If I see the word eggs somewhere. I'm just don't
You know done
Hi, mercy are you into manga or video novels? Will you read some loon ones? Yes done. I answered that one
I'm sorry, I can't see this
I can't see this
It's too far away from me
Can I can I pull this up hold on let me pull this to a different screen
Okay, oh
Oh, hold on. I need to take off my eyepatch for this
Okay, um, what inspired you to be a vtuber? Honestly
When keys are not I said
Uh, did you help create the avatar? Absolutely not. Can you tell us something behind the scenes? I didn't even get to name
Oh
I feel so naked without my eyepatch, but I gotta see yeah favorite content creators that aren't vtubers
No next question
Uh, I guess like if
No, no next question. I can't think of anyone
If given a chance to collab with any vtuber, who would it be?
Anyone really
Anyone really it's just um
Excuse me
Oh, I know I know who
If I could stream Natalia Sana, I want to tell her I learned
I'm cold from her
Thanks for teaching me Japanese
Um
If you're a vtuber avatar came to life, what do you think I'll say about you?
Senpai is mine
Get the fuck away from me
What's wrong with you?
She probably roast me real me
Oop k-fave drop I need my eyepatch back on
Oh
I'll be a cat fight pretty much
Okay, let's see
Uh
Congrats on debut mercy, thank you
My question is in your opinion after working in violor for some time now
How would you describe their management also ignore the question if you don't want to answer?
I don't want to get you in trouble
Um, probably not gonna get in trouble probably not maybe a little spanking but nah
Spanking my scrawny honestly should probably
wouldn't care
but
Oh management is great. Honestly management is great. I do not respect management. Just kidding
Just kidding I'm kidding
Um
Management is actually very competent. They answer my questions quickly. Um, I get a lot more freedom than I thought I would
I get a lot of freedom than I thought I would um
Um
Usually I would ask a simple question and then I'll get back to me almost as soon as as soon as I can so
I think um
I think management's pretty good
pretty good
I think it's more funny is uh
What's funny is that I expected to be like
There's some things that that management does tell me no no not at this time no no no and I'm okay with that
but I expected kind of like a
Like a more strict type of management is very it's been very lax
kind of like you know
Instead of like your strict parents. It'll be like you're cool
Your cool aunt or your cool uncle that still has to take care of you
But they let you do more things that maybe your parents don't
Kind of things like that
They let's just say that they'll wrangle me when they need to
If I go
If I go balls to the walls and they'll and then management goes
Mmm
Your channel might get struck and now and then I'll be like fair fair kind of thing. Okay
Does that make sense the I'm probably
So things
Okay
So things like that would
Generally, I'd generally say that they're very good, but I I am a lot more freedom than I expected
Sometimes I get to know sometimes I get a maybe not this time
But overall it's been pretty respectful
Even though I will clown on management when I can
That's all push it to the limits. I don't want to push things to the limit because I have a high respect
For scrawny and I don't want scrawny mad or upset because um, I'm just that thankful
That's all
Okay, that's all the questions I had whoa
How long have I been screaming for?
Ah, I got time. I got lots of time. I have so much energy right now
Sometimes give me all the energy
You
Oops
My bad
Okay, yeah
I thought I had everything ready. I didn't
Was that in some music as well. Whoa. Okay. Wow. I thought I added that in I didn't wow
So there we go. Okay. Oh, what was it?
Yeah, I had like a little speech and then I saw I saw that there was no audio
I just noticed you I can see your ears through your bangs. Yeah, my my my bangs are pretty thin paper thin even
Okay, uh, what was I saying? Oh my gosh, uh, I had a little speech
I wanted to talk about a little bit of my v-tipping journey. I hope you guys don't mind
um
About basically like my journey to get here
Just so you guys can get to know me better a little bit
Excuse me
So
Um
I
Auditioned to a lot of companies
Some gave me some chances. Some didn't uh, I'd never made it
to
Never made it into a place before though
Um, I got lots of views on my videos on my auditions and stuff
but together, um, I
When I first started my journey
forgetting here
I
Had a daruma doll and I filled in one eye and I said I want to get into a v-tipping company
And when I do I'm going to fill in the other da the other eye
And I showed strongy my daruma doll
of uh
Of the eye filled in and I was really happy that I was able to finally fill it in after after so long
And I was really happy
I started this journey actually
with
Serenity from vnu
Serenity and I worked very hard to achieve our dreams together
So I would consider serenity one of my best friends
And we cheered each other on all the time
So when she got into
vnu
I was very happy. I was cheering her on all the time
So
When I got into v allure we kind of
Got together and was like we did it. We did it. We reached our dreams
So we reached our dreams together
And I feel very happy about that
Which is why if you guys were like, oh, why is serenity so into why was she so into this company? It's because
We are close friends. We are close friends
So we spent nights sometimes together, uh
Oh gosh, I'm tearing up now because I love her so much
Um
We would spend some nights together reviewing our uh
Our audition videos with each other, um for companies and then we would uh
And then we could oh gosh
And
And we would talk about our dreams for hours and then you know, we would uh do calls together and stuff it was just it was just
It was just great
So when I got into the company and she got into the into a company
We were so happy for each other that we both reached our dreams finally because we both cheered each other on for so long
We both cheered each other for so long
And I'm so glad she fits perfectly in B&U and I feel like I fit perfectly in Bialore
So
She's my she's my best friend, uh
So she's my best friend and uh, she's been cheering me on
And she's like, I love you and then we go. I love you too. So we've been on this journey together for a while
I'll say some weird things too. It's it's it's weird
And I feel like I suit mercy perfectly and she suits serenity perfectly
Serenity perfectly
so
We are both very happy
We are both very happy that we achieved her dreams
And we're gonna keep doing it we're keep gonna we're just we're gonna keep going
So
We work so hard to get here
I asked serenity before stream can I tell the story and then she goes yeah, you can so I asked permission
Will you two have a collab duh we're gonna have a collab
Duh we're gonna have a collab
We're like really close friends and stuff so I can't wait. I can't wait. Um
Not not anything not anything um sassy though. It's gonna be like a normal collab. Sorry
So
I was so happy like
Strani, I might post it up later, but strani when she heard the story
Now I gotta cry again
She loved it so much she commissioned art of me and serenity and I was like
I'm gonna show up. She probably show it later, but strani did that and I was so touched by it
I
Sorry, I'm sorry. I'm crying
So I'm so happy to be here you guys don't know
A lot we worked to get here
I
Just why I'm gonna work really hard
To make strani proud and I'm gonna work really hard to make all my supplies really happy
It was funny because
I
My mom is my mom pulled me aside one day
And decided to read my fortune for no reason and I I was like, okay
So
It was like
You're going to get a job
And it was very specific it was like you're gonna get a job and a woman who
Where's a lot of black and maybe has black hair
Black hair and this is going to be a very strange a little bit of different work
But you're going to get a job. You're gonna
Be fulfilled and she's gonna help you get this job and she's gonna work and
Make your dream and help you reach your goals and I was like, oh
At the time I didn't think anything of it
And now I feel like you know the woman that that mama
Mama said was uh
Was uh was strani
So I'm really happy. Sorry teary up
So I'm really happy to be here like truly
I
Really love it here. Uh, okay. Let's let's move on to like a funnier story. Okay
Let's let's move on to a funnier story
I
I'm still gonna cry. Okay. I'm sorry
I did not get the email for joining me or until several days after after they ended
So I thought oh, okay
I thought I didn't get it
I
I thought I didn't get in
I thought I didn't get in and so I know it's it's rude manners
But I was like, okay. Well
Whatever they might not respond to me, but here we go. I'll send an email asking for some feedback
I send an email
Getting for some feedback then I was like, okay, whatever. I gotta move on
I gotta move on then I get a message a few days later saying oh fucking shit
Oh you got in
I want
And I got
But like I was really into
um
Into violor
So I was like, oh well, you know, I didn't get in but I'm going to support the company because I think I really believe in
scrawny stream. I really believe in scrawny stream. So I
I started uh doing uh some things where I was like, okay. I want to like, you know promote them a little bit, you know
uh
So I got pulled into an emergency call basically like my sign
Gave me the basic rundown and everything and
And uh
I got in I got in it was I got a bit of a different
I'm not sure about the interview process for the other girls, but mine was a little rushed
I got in a little later than the rest of the girls because well, I
So
I was like, oh my god
I was flabbergasted actually I screamed so hard when I got the emails saying like, you know
They they want to talk they want to talk to me
and um
I screamed so hard. So when I got onto the call the scrawny
Uh to to kind of do my interview. I was like
The entire time that one was real, but I'm using it as emphasis
The entire time
So it was same day I got in and then
Um, it was a bit of a journey. It was a bit of a journey trying to get get used to everything
I read like the contract over and over etc
And it was really good
So
I'm I'm here now
So I I did get here a little late. I did get a little later get here a little later
And I had to basically play catch-up
With everyone a little bit. So I'm so glad I'm here now
So I'm so glad to be here with my supplies
So I'm
What do you call it?
I'm glad to be here. I'm so happy to to meet my supplies and I've been waiting for so long. I've been uh
I've been like working so hard to meet you guys
Or so so long
So yeah, whoo emotions out
Me
Okay, so I'm I'm truly happy to be here. I'm truly am
So, uh, I'm very new once again. I'm very new. Uh, basically I'm named uh, it's like a training montage and a growth
Uh story with you guys. I I even asked, uh, scrawny if it was okay
Because if I was so new and she was like, you know, she was like, of course, of course, I'll help you and I was like
Yeah
So I'm I'm happy. I'm happy. I hope I helped to make you all happy. Um
I can't be everything of course, but I'm gonna try my darn darkness best to be
a great kohai
For all of my lovely supplies
So that's that's really all I wanted to really say about my funky stories about how I got here, et cetera
I know that we are a bit of a bit of a different company
But we are just like any other girls and but and we just do, you know, a little on the side
So I think it's great to be here honestly
And I can't wait to play more games with everyone as well
Um, well play games that I haven't really played or I'm re-picking up again because I want to
Let's start over. I I totally forgot everything that happened
So yeah, I'm so glad to be given this opportunity
Oh
That's all I really had to say
Oh, we went through our our new and new uh, uh, our new
Our new tags and so I'm really happy about that. Yeah
Do you guys have any questions for me now? This is open question time
Because I'm free to open uh, if you guys don't think of a question now you can ask it on maro later no guarantees that I will uh
I will I will
Answer them simply because
I I'm so exhausted
How content are you looking forward to making the most?
If given the chance I would love to do a concert like a 3d concert or something
I'm making making like my original songs come to life songs are expensive to make by the way, so um
Um
So I have like a list of like my my songs and my notes that I just think of and then I just kind of want to like bring them to life
I want the I want to bring them to life
What's your top five yand favorite yandere is me me me me and me
Let's see. Hold on it's going up. You guys have a lot of questions
Um
Oh, right
I'm so silly
Another thing when I auditioned I actually auditioned to be uh
To be icy
I picked out a name and everything was so awesome
I picked out a name and everything but turns out it's named or already chosen
I'm so glad that I didn't get I didn't get um
I didn't get uh, I see though. I think I'm I'm a good fit fit here
Do you have a block blow blow high I do have a blow high
I've actually waited uh of since
Since the start of culvin to get one
Why are you so cute? It's because you
Because of you senpai. I'm winking but like it doesn't work on the eye patch
If you close the scissors on your head will your hair fall off? Probably. Luckily. Uh, they're kind of kind of bad and rusty. Hey
Okay
I want your merch everyone else talked about their merch. All right
You forgot
I got so so teary eyed. I forgot. Yes. I do have merch available now. I believe I have a
I have some
I have a keychain
an acrylic stand
joggers
Uh a t-shirt and a hoodie
I I really love the art on the t-shirt slash hoodie as well. I think it's really really cool
Any ideas for future outfit design slash
slash style
I I do have an idea in my mind
I don't know when it will happen, but I do want a like
A first date outfit
The eyes emerge stop stop
So
Uh, I was looking like you know first date outfit where I'll wear like a cute little outfit
To go on dates with templates like a kind of casual casual outfit, you know
Would you ever release your own brand of scissors or eye patches?
Scissors maybe
eye patches
I think you can make your own so I think you'll be fine with that
We'll ask the modeler for a toga outfit stop it
Scissors I think I would be very picky with my scissors
But if I could have scissors that in this kind of brownish in my opinion
I feel like my scissors in my hair are kind of rose gold. I feel like they're kind of rose gold
I know they're kind of got they're a little
Redder than brass I think so I I I had canon them or rather canonize them as rose gold
I
Mercy branded cage it's all don't worry about that
Uh, did was there any other outfits? Oh chat goes by so fast. I'm not used to this. I'm not used to seeing chat go by pretty fast
so
You see, are you happy? Yes, I'm very happy
What three superpowers would you like to have?
um
mind control
telekinesis
Super string
If I want to draw fan art, what would you prefer I draw anything you want you have freedom of will
I'm not going to stop you. Um, the only thing I don't like is art with like
Alternate art of like me with a male character or a male. Oh, see. I don't like that
um
for example, you know, I don't want to
with like
Curie curie you
from yakuza
But I don't mind if we're like both thumbs up, you know like thumbs up
Kicking butt or something
How long have I known serenity jeez
It's just like a
three
three years plus
There's dream sponsor you'd like to have
Hmm
You know those like PC PC cases and stuff I would love to have one of those
Um
When we get some karaoke streams, yes, but I cannot guarantee that I'm very good
If you're expecting Celine Dion or someone, uh, that's not gonna happen
Can you play flower sun and rain? Oh, actually, that's the game that I really wanted to play
Yeah, you have a favorite meme
I reference a lot of like different memes so the ones that I reference the most are probably like any like
Like ghost story jobs
Jesus go stand a bitch
You know how to drive. Yes, I do know how to drive. I actually have have my advanced license
I
Off cut off cut. Sorry. Wow, Brian get
Vtuber brain rot
Off club potential with the girls. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. I would love that
I've asked Ronnie to be like
Can I go over over there so I can collab with everyone?
I
Can fan art have blood. Yes, of course
You do any fan art you want. I just personal opinion. I can't even stop you if you wanted to like draw me like
Going knowing
something
I
Are you forklift certified now?
Have you played
The ends for no
I can't I can't stop you I can't stop you but I if I don't like the subject for example like oh if you draw me like
With like I don't know
Some character or an oath or an OC
I might not be very happy about it, but I appreciate your work
Otherwise all fan arts good
New plan on playing any smt spins off like strange journey or a devil survivor
I have
in my collection
The original ps2 version so I'm hoping they will play them on original hardware
I'm hoping I'm hoping I gotta figure things out though. So I would love to um
Play I even have
I have I made some room on my desk on my desk in order to put on the
Well, oh it's called again the tube the tube
What's if he is the tube?
The crt right I have room I put on
A room uh, I have room to put a crt on my desk if I wanted to
If I wanted to uh
If I wanted to really play like retro games on there, I want to play retro games because I grew up not playing games
I
It's alt fan art with faceless mail. Okay. Yes. Yes. Yes. If you have any more questions. I saw my twitter my alternate twitter
How far retro are you talking?
I may play like I don't know. I don't know whatever I feel like honestly
I still have to set it all up though. So there's no promises but
In my mind in my mind
I want to build up my tolerance for 3d games by playing older 3d games in order to kind of build up
You know a tolerance
Um
I have to set it up. Oh, sorry
I turned a little bit because I went to look at the crt that's still over there. I have actually have two crt's
Because I wasn't sure if the one I currently have is too big. So I have a smaller one as well
Okay, I just didn't want to play oh
I
Did you know a devil saga?
Oh
What else do I have?
There's this one kind of like western kind of rpg. I thought was cool as well. I also have that
Uh, I have
What wait, wait, wait, I remember the name of the rpg wild arms. Yeah, I have wild arms
Yeah wild arms. Oh, you guys really really read my mind. I was like oh, I get a little western rpg
And I was like, well listen, I had to turn around physically to take a look at it
Like I wanted to play that
I don't have good vision
Our our the arse our series
Our tour isn't my best. I'm a little something. Uh, maybe some atelier games
Atelier games will be fine. Um
You drink coffee. Uh, no, I don't drink coffee. In fact, I'm drinking tea right now
I
Kind of see oh shoot, I don't remember
Oh
I don't know what
Is it echinacea it might be echinacea
You came with playing third person games sometimes it depends really depends
It might be echinacea. Yeah
Oh
That's worrying what kind of tea I drink, uh, I just put one in I have like a whole pile
One of your plans for youtube membership streams probably a lot of asmr streams, um
Doodling streams, maybe
What's your favorite type of tea? Uh, the current tea I like is right now peppermint vanilla
We play through higurashi uminickle. I played higurashi the first chapter. Yes, I play the first chapter
What asmr mic do you have? Oh
Strani if you were paying attention to strani strani and
Management vlr has provided me with a three deal
A three deal I've got the uh, the one
XLR the ones where you can put in XLR cables. Yeah
She also, uh, provided, uh, vlr
Also, well, it's not really her. It was management. Uh, provided me a
Interface as well to work with the
radio
So I'm able to
to strain at my
Peak at my peak
Three deal free space XLR. Thank you. Yeah, that one
It's a little
a little, um
Sensitive I found out it's because when I was doing some recording sometimes my stomach would rumble and it goes
Grrr, and you would hear and they're recording. I was like, oh
I kind of interfered
I kind of interface us
Scarlett, what was it again?
Management, I know you're here
Scarlett
Maybe
You
That one
First gen focus right to i2. There you go. Thank you, my nice son
So I have that uh, I'm still kind of getting used to the three deal
I probably won't use it like a regular person would because I don't
I'm very ignorant of asmr stuff. So for triggers and stuff. I'm thinking about getting some things some some beauty
beauty beauty
tools
And trying them out on the three deal. I'm thinking about that. I still gotta go out and get them at like a discount shop
Are all asmr is gonna be spicy. Yes and no
Some will be spicy some will not be spicy
But I'm we're probably gonna play it safe and the spicy ones will be on patreon. Sorry
Seems you're interested in a bunch of suit of 51 games to see your favorite not necessarily
I just happen to be interested in like kind of
experimental games
Can you give us a hint on the asmr themes?
um
I haven't thought about it that far yet to be honest
I haven't thought about it from that far yet
Thank you for the tippy wippy
Hands i'm playing no more heroes. I want to play no more heroes on the Wii
I heard that you can pick up the phone on the Wii remote and then the sound comes out of the Wii remote like the
Like a phone
So I want to play you like that and I found and then apparently you can jork it you can jork the
The the Wii remote. I want to try it with the Wii
Johnny said equipment purchases are still going to come out of your future patrex though. Is that true? Yes
Only a part of it though. So it's easier
So it's easier so the cost of it is a little bit more down. Don't worry about it
Any interest in deadly premonitions or swearee games? Okay
Hey, I have oh my gosh. I my model's lagging. Oh, no
Uh, uh stop lagging you there you go
Daily premonitions, no probably not
Do you know why because I tried to play deadly premonition premonition and then uh on PC
and then I set stop and everything and it froze
at
I could not take out the screwdriver out of
The toolbox and then I went onto the forms and and google this and do you know what google said?
And I said how do I play this on PC know what I've said buy it on switch
Buy it on switch. It is an unplayable in PC form. So most likely I'm probably not gonna play
Because I don't want to buy another game again
So I don't want to go through that, you know
I don't want to go through that. Yeah, I don't
I don't want to
Yeah, pretty much it literally said how do I play it on PC? You don't I was like, how do I improve? How do I uh
Is there any any I don't know patches in order to to optimize the game and they said you want to play deadly premonition on PC
Buy it on switch
So
So no, I don't think so no until I get over my piss until I get over my anger about the PC part
Feelings on ps2 era horror like rule of rules. I never grew up on
On that type of game. I never got to play games. My first console was
a the ds lite so uh take that as you will my first
Home console was a ps4. So also take that as you will
I never got to experience the games that you guys played
So I'm excited to try out games that I've never tried before as well
I know like a lot of girls really love the retro games. I kind of don't want to step on their toes
but at the same time just kind of like
I want to play
older
jb
RPG
Maybe visual novel type games. Can I do that?
Am I gonna step on any toes?
Any games in mind as I said
as I said, um probably digital devil saga atelier series
wild arms are whatever
That word was
So
Yeah, those are the type of games that I want to try
As well and I want to play no more heroes specifically on the Wii because I want to draw. I want to draw the remote
Have you ever played or
Wanna leak leak leak. Oh, is that what it's called? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, uh
No
I have it
But yeah, I love I love those
I love those up any plans to playing
Uh, what was it doki doki literature club? Maybe
Maybe
It's a big maybe mostly because I already played
It already and I'm I remember I it's still fresh in my mind
So I kind of want to play games that are either not that fresh in my mind yet or
Kind of something that I haven't really played
So I would really do you like platformer games. I'm really bad at platformers
Uh, I don't have but I I do like playing them
I want to play uh some mario games as well some some mario games
I actually got my hands on mario like the remake of mario rpg
But I'd really like to try that out as well. I know it's the remake. It's not like the real deal
But I I have it in order to experience it for the first time
So I really for the DS games I have tons of games that I played on the DS. I have such fond memories of them
I don't have a DS that I can stream from though, so
I cannot stream DS games
Thousand Year Door is fantastic if you haven't played it. I played Thousand Year Door on the GameCube
I managed to borrow GameCube from a friend and
I played it. I played the whole thing
I
I wasn't expecting to see harvester on someone's schedule. Oh
Okay, this is gonna sound weird, but I learned of harvester. I know of harvester and I played a bit of harvester
in university
In
uh, we were playing a bunch of
uh, games so the first game that I played in a
For my class, it's a
history of video games
Uh course that I took uh first game. I played uh kind of like the FMV style was
Seventh guest
So
I played seventh guest and oh my gosh, I found out the one
Game the the the virus game was based off of your clock. So when I was trying to play it, it was it's rough
It was rough
That's a course of course
Of course
Check your university. You'll probably you'll probably find a lot of fine courses
Uh, I didn't get to take this one, but there was uh history of anime
Uh and
History of hentai as well. I didn't get to take those two, but I really wanted to
Oh, did you get to play hotel dusk on the ds? Yes
But yeah
Actually, I actually decided on my own to like do
I borrowed the syllabus from a friend who was taking some of those courses and I I decided to study it
Oh my god
For funsies
For funsies so it was really it was really interesting very informative very eye-opening
So I really liked uh, what did you learn? Oh, I just learned uh basically
Maybe this should be a membership stream. I'll give you guys my own personal uh lesson sensei mercy
So I think that'll be fun. Hmm. I'm getting a little tired though senpai. I'm getting a little tired though
I gotta put you guys back in the cage
I think it'll be very interesting and very eye-opening for everyone you guys can probably see
the history of it starting with
uh
like hokusai and developing on into uh printed formats into
Into and then uh video formats and then so on and so forth. I think I'll be really cool
Do you get at least get a pillow? Of course I gave you the doggy bed and everything
So, uh, is any of the girls streaming right now or is it just me? I'm the late night streamer
I'm the late night streamer. So by tomorrow, let's go over my schedule again. Let me take a look see at it
Let me take a look see at my schedule again
I forget what I put on there, but I I got all the games on there. Hopefully it's he's going to be okay
Oh
Where did I post it? There we go. Uh, next game is killer seven. I'm not sure if I'm if I
I don't know how to optimize it
As much but I'm gonna try my best after that. So morey and then my first time asmr
Hopefully I'm gonna pick up all the stuff that I wanted to get for you guys to try it out
I'm very ignorant stuff. I'm bad at it. Please. Please forgive me
Uh difficult game about climbing. I figured a rage game would make you guys really happy. I'm
I'm a bit of a screamer
Uh, I'm very loud as well
Uh designing gen mates outfits. I love fashion a lot. So I'd love to design my gen mates some cute clothes
Um
Harvester, yeah
and then
Death mark death mark is
I've played death mark before I just left it off for so long. We might as well start it all over again
So
That that will be really fun
So I hope today was fun as fun for you as it was for me
I'd love to get to know my supplies more and you got your taste. Listen to you guys
Uh, I know my taste and everything. Um, let me double check who's on right now
Mark is really good. Have you played persona series? Yeah, I played persona. It's not my favorite though
I
Honestly, this is pretty late. I'm a late night streamer. So
It's fine. I think there's no one on so I guess that means
Let me see
I don't think anyone's on that I
Oops
I'm checking if anyone from beanie was is on but I don't think anyone is on
um
So, yeah, that's all today. Um, I was going to oh, yeah, I do have merch available now. I'm super excited
This is my first time ever getting merch
First time getting merch so I'm really excited
So I I hope to see you all again same time
tomorrow
And I hope if there's any like dying questions. Yeah, I don't think so
Yeah, I think it's good. Yeah
I'm gonna head to bed. Um, I got quite quite sick. So I'm gonna rest up a little bit. I'll keep I'll keep you guys posted
Uh, I'll probably get a lot of rest tomorrow
Mm-hmm. Yeah, okay
Time to go
Oh, I don't I've never made a greeting for my like a goodbye greeting
Oh
Scream for mercy